bonsoir à toutes et à tous je suis venu
vous présenter un projet ambitieux
complexe
un petit peu utopique
mais qui me motive profondément faire
renaître une forêt primaire en europe de
l'ouest
une forêt primaire c'est une forêt qui
n'a jamais été exploité depuis son
origine bon
si elle l'a été
un temps suffisant s'est écoulé pour que
le caractère primaire ait pu revenir
mais ça c'est très long ça se compte en
siècle
il faudrait primaires c'est aussi
un optimum un summum en matière
d'écologie on peut pas imaginer mieux le
maximum de captation du gaz carbonique
atmosphérique
le maximum de stockage du carbone dans
des troncs devenue énorme
le maximum de fertilité des sols le
maximum de
l'alimentation des nappes phréatiques
par de l'eau pure
le maximum de résilience de la forêt
le maximum de beauté forestière ça ça me
touche beaucoup mais n'oublions pas ce
qui est probablement le plus important
le maximum de biodiversité
c'est dans les forêts qu'on la trouve
qu'on trouve ce maximum et ça comprend
les petits animaux mais aussi les grands
nous avons
nous avions devrais je dire une
magnifique forêt primaire en europe pas
tout près d'ici puisque c'est en pologne
ça s'appelle la forêt de bialowieza pour
moi c'est un souvenir inoubliable
une beauté très difficile à décrire
c'est très très beau
malheureusement les choses sont ce
qu'elles sont et les problèmes
politiques au sein du gouvernement
polonais actuelle nous amène à penser
que la forêt de bialowieza
ça son exploitation est programmée et il
est même probable qu'elle ait commencé
bon si elle est exploitée
c'est à dire si elle perd son caractère
primaire
c'est triste à dire mais nous n'aurons
plus en europe que des forêts
secondaires
forêts secondaires c'est à dire basse
des structures et des arts trop nombreux
et trop petit pas de canopée
et une faune incomplète parce que tous
les grands animaux ont été détruits par
la chasse
c'est pas juste parce que beaucoup de
pays
comparables à l'europe
regardez des morceaux significative de
leurs forêts primaires
je pense aux états unis
au canada à la russie
au japon à l'australie et la tasmanie à
la nouvelle zélande etc tous ces pays là
ont encore des morceaux de forêt
primaire et ils en sont drôlement
content parce que ça attire des milliers
de touristes
et puis ça permet aux scientifiques
locaux de faire des recherches du très
haut niveau parce que les recherches sur
les forêts primaires c'est très loin
d'être terminée
[Applaudissements]
il faut pas croire qu'il faille être un
spécialiste
pour distinguer une forêt primaire d'une
forêt secondaire pas du tout c'est du
premier coup d'oeil
et c'est la beauté qui est qui marque
immédiatement n'importe qui est capable
de dire savent c'est une forêt tellement
belle qu'elle est primaire
un collègue écologiste forestiers des
états unis m'a donné cette comparaison
qui est assez forte ou aller voir mais
qui à laquelle j'adhère totalement
ce monsieur s'appelle james balog
et il dit la forêt primaire et à la
forêt secondaire ce que le grand canyon
du colorado est un égout
c'est clair non pour moi ça me convient
pas de n'avoir comme forêt que des mg ou
doux doubin le projet que je suis venu
vous présenter
[Applaudissements]
un poids important
des journaux malades mal informés on dit
que ça serait un territoire mis sous
cloche où l'être humain ne pourraient
pas rentrer je m'élève contre ça c'est
totalement fou
quand je dis nous c'est que mia
maintenant je suis plus du tout le seul
à travailler là dessus nous avons une
association
avec des milliers de membres et des
dizaines de spécialistes qui travaillent
sur tous les aspects du problème
bon
les gens ils seront les bienvenus les
visites sont non seulement autorisé
mais favorisée
avec tout de même une contrainte qui est
de ne pas abîmer ce qui entoure les
visiteurs ça ça paraît bien normal on
évitera de marché au marché au sol parce
que sur les trains dans les très
vieilles forêts le solde vient nous
devient meubles et si on marche trop on
risque de
d'étouffer les racines mêmes de dieu les
armes on en a la certitude maintenant
donc on va marcher sur des des
caillebotis en bois comme dans beaucoup
de parcs nationaux d'ailleurs aux états
unis ou en australie à m de large 30 cm
de haut et puis ça circule comme ça
voilà c'était pas compliqué
notre projet
il a des adversaires
c'est presque obligé
les premiers sont les chasseurs
ça va pas être commode nous sommes prêts
à discuter avec les fédérations de
chasseurs mais je sens que ça va pas
être commode parce qu'il n'aime pas du
tout qu'on restreignent lors
leurs surfaces d'activités
on va aller prier toutefois de d'exercer
leurs talents non pas dans les soixante
dix mille hectares
qui sont au centre mais dans la zone
tampon buffer zone
étroite et y arriver
incidemment 70 mille hectares il faut
pas prendre ça soit gigantesque
c'est copié sur la forêt de bélouve déjà
et c'est un carré de 26 kilomètres de
côtes et on peut pas dire que ce soit
gigantesque et moi qui ai des
des
contacts méditerranéen parce que
j'habite au bord de la méditerranée je
voudrais vous parler des baléares ça
c'est majorque
très grand
sas et minorque
comme son nom l'indiqué c'est beaucoup
plus petit et bien ça c'est 70 mille
hectares un petit point sur la carte de
la méditerranée il faut pas me faire
croire que ces gigantesques non
parmi les
adversaires oui il n'ya pas que les
chasseurs il ya aussi ça a l'air idiot
mais je vais vous dire les forestiers
sont pas rejetés mais pas tous dans le
même sac mais beaucoup de forestiers
sont persuadés qu'ils sont là pour
pour diriger l'action de la forêt
pour
améliorer ses performances et corriger
ses défauts l'homme vous voyez ce pas
seulement les forestiers d'ailleurs on
est un peu tous comme ça l'homme se
croient supérieurs à la nature
écoutez ce qu'on dit ce que disent les
les écoles forestière
une forêt que l'on exploite pas
elle va s'étouffer et mourir
c'est complètement idiot et en plus
c'est c'est d'une présomption folle je
voudrais juste rappeler qu'
il ya des forêts sur cette planète
depuis le milieu du dévonien c'est à
dire 5
530 millions d'années
comment un fait cette pauvre forêt pour
vivre sans forestier on le sait pas mais
elle apparemment elle était absolument
superbe d'après les fossiles qu'on en
possèdent
y a un
an pour un groupe d'opposants
d'adversaires d'opposants plus tôt c'est
ce qu'ils veulent que tout aille très
vite six siècles
voilà la durée ça va être six siècles
parce que on va partir d'une forêt
secondaire il va falloir qu'elle se
change en forêt primaire c'est compliqué
il ya 3 3 stade trois vagues floristique
successives mais il faut six siècles
bon
fit d'attendre qu'est ce qu'on va faire
pendant ces six siècles on va pratiquer
ce qu'on appelle maintenant la libre
évolution c'est à dire que on ne retire
rien en ajoute rien on retire rien c'est
à dire si un arbre tombe un coup de vent
ou bien il est mort tout simplement on
le laisse au sol il va se décomposer sur
le sol et ben c'est le meilleur moyen
pour que le carbone et les ions minéraux
que l'arbre a absorbé pendant son
existence reviennent au sol c'est ça qui
fait la first fertilité des sols dans
les forêts primaires
mais cette libre évolution l est pas
après si elle est même pas admise par
tous les forestiers j'ai discuté avec
l'un de vire pas très longtemps il avait
vu une forêt avec des arbres tombés
comme ça
et il m'a dit passez moi l'expression
c'est un bordel informe
j'en déduis que ce monsieur
il dit manquer les bases d'écologie
nécessaire pour comprendre comment un
seul s'enrichit moi ça me fait peur de
voir que nos forêts sont entre les mains
de gens qui dont certains au moins ne
connaissent pas les bases de l'écologie
on va terminer par quelques remarques
conclusive
c'est ambitieux vous l'avez compris
c'est
un peu utopique parce que personne ne
sait ce qui aura sur notre planète dans
six siècles
mais c'est un projet
citoyen qui part de la base qui n'a pas
donc il n'a aucune visée commerciale ou
mercantiles
et voilà notre projet à nous c'est de
créer un patrimoine
pour les générations futures pour que
nos descendants il est un aperçu de ce à
quoi ressemble et l'europe à l'origine
avant l'arrivée des êtres humains
600 en
un mot sur le budget un budget sur 600
ans est un homme inquiétant mais non
n'ayez pas d'inquiétude parce que le
lait parcelle en question vont devoir
nous être dévolue par des décisions
politiques nationales et surtout
européenne c'est surtout l'europe qui
nous soutient dans cette affaire bon
donc on n'achète rien c'est plutôt bien
et une fois qu'on aura la parcelle
est bien là libre évolution c'est ne
rien faire ne rien faire ça devrait pas
coûter cher
bon faut pas que j'exagère aussi parce
qu'il ya en tout de même besoin des
budgets tout simplement parce qu'il va
arriver des cohortes de touristes
et il va falloir les loger les nourrir
donc il faut des installations
hôtelières ça c'est sûr et puis ça va
attirer des scientifiques du monde
entier ça je prends exemple sur la
pologne actuelle
ces gens là il va falloir aussi d
accueillir leur donner un laboratoire et
une salle de conférence une salle de
réunion une bibliothèque etc donc voilà
un minimum de budget mais il n'y a rien
de
d'extraordinaire et de grandiose dans ce
budget puisque pour l'essentiel la
nature travaillent pour elles mêmes et
ça vous aura pas échappé l'atr la nature
travaillent bénévolement gratuitement et
d'ailleurs elle fait ça beaucoup mieux
que nous
l'homme qui se croient supérieurs à la
nature il se trompe complètement parce
que quand on voit l'état actuel des
forêts au niveau mondial on se dit qu'on
n'aurait pas dû les confier à l'être
humain parce que vraiment c'est une
situation déplorable
bon un projette donc qu'ambitieux
légèrement utopique mais je tiens à vous
le dire
ça soulève de grands espoirs notamment
dans la jeune génération
si vous voulez vous nous aider et bien
la chose à faire c'est de vous
intéresser aux forêts une petite forêt
secondaires comme on en a partout ici eh
bien ça mérite vraiment qu'on s'y
intéresse qu on se plonge dedans qu'on
essaye de comprendre ce réseau énorme
d'interaction entre les êtres vivants et
je vous garantis que c'est d'une
complexité énorme n'y a pas un cerveau
humain
je pèse mes mots ya pas un cerveau
qui est capable de comprendre totalement
une forêt même une forêt secondaire
et c'est trop compliqué à comprendre
dans la partie aérienne et dans la
partie souterraine qui reste encore
assez mal connu
voilà donc mon espoir c'est que ça
continue à soulever de grossesse de vos
espérances chez les jeunes et que ce
projet dans l'avenir ils puissent être
copiés
parce que quand les autres pays
européens verront sépare très compliqué
que ça coûte pas cher je crois qu'on
tiendra à la solution merci beaucoup
ah ah